[Music]
what if we could engineer a gigantic
mega structure capable of harvesting
every bit of the sun's energy something
known as a Dyson Sphere how long would
it take to construct this mega shell
where would we find all the materials
needed and what can we do with this
structure once we finally built it this
is what if and here's what would happen
if we could build a Dyson Sphere around
the Sun the idea of a Dyson Sphere was
well stolen from aliens in 1960 astro
physicist Freeman Dyson theorized
another civilization that found a way to
meet their ever increasing energy and
space demands they rearranged their
solar system this hypothetical advanced
civilization built a hollow sphere
around their own Sun and provided
themselves with an incredible amount of
energy and habitable real estate but
what about us how would we go about
building this space level structure
theoretically if we built a Dyson Sphere
we'd have access to a colossal 400
septillion watts of solar energy that's
a trillion times more power than our
entire civilization consumes today the
problem is no known material is strong
enough to handle all the space radiation
and even if we created one in very large
quantities a tiny gravitational pull
towards the Sun would make our solid
sphere uninhabitable not to mention that
it would be totally unstable every
meteor strike would push a part of the
sphere towards the star but all these
issues can be solved with a simple
adjustment instead of building a solid
Dyson Sphere we could build a Dyson
swarm a myriad of solar collectors with
their individual orbits around the Sun
let's start with a small station one
that's able to provide the energy needed
for this whole construction project we'd
begin on Mercury it would become our
space mine for the iron and oxygen we'd
need from those elements we'd make
highly reflective solar collectors the
giant mirrors would reflect light into a
small solar power plant from there it
would be the energy to where we need it
we'd probably demolish mercury entirely
before we moved on to Venus Mars and the
outer planets even nearby asteroids
would be decimated however even just
deconstructing mercury which supplies us
with enough energy to power up our
supercomputers and boost interstellar
exploration maybe we'd even build
earth-like oases large rotating space
colonies in the habitable zone of our
solar system maybe if we're lucky we'd
find other more efficient sources of
energy to help us master space travel
like artificially generated black holes
but that's a story for another what if
you